most cells in the human body just go
about their business on a daily basis in
a fairly respectable way let's say that
i have some cell here this could be
maybe a a skin cell or really any cell
in any tissue of the body and as it as
that tissue is growing or it's replacing
dead cells the the the cells will
experience mitosis and replicate
themselves make perfect copies of each
other and then those two maybe will
experience mitosis
and then if they realize that gee you
know it's getting a little bit of it's
getting a little crowded there are other
cells in my neighborhood
there are other cells in my
neighborhood they'll recognize that
they'll say you know i'm going to stop
growing a little bit that's called
contact inhibition
and so they'll just start going and then
let's say one of them experiences a
little defect
a little defect and he says you know
what gee you know i'm i'm not really you
know something's a little bit wrong with
me i the cell recognize this in myself
and the cells will actually kill
themselves that's how the good of of
cellular citizens they are they'll kind
of
make way for other healthy cells so this
guy might even kill himself if he
realizes that there's something wrong
with it there's actually a cellular
mechanism that does that it's called
apoptosis
and i want to make this very clear this
isn't somehow some type of outside
influence on the cell the cell itself
recognizes that it's somehow damaged and
it just destroys itself so apoptosis
so that's the regular circumstance even
when there is a mutation and just to
give you an idea even if mutations are
relatively infrequent and i don't know
the exact frequencies at which mutations
occur i suspect it's of different
frequencies and different types of
tissues there are on the order of
on the order of a hundred billion
one let me do a different color
they're on the order of 100
billion
new cells in the human body
per day
per day so even if you only even if a
mutation only occurs one in a million
times you're still dealing with roughly
100 000 mutations and maybe most of the
mutations you know maybe they're just
some little random things that don't
really do a lot but if the mutations are
a little bit more severe the cell will
recognize it and destroy itself and i
want to make a clear a very clear point
here i'm talking about the cell the the
cells of the body or most of the body
this could be the cells in my in my eye
or the cells in my brain or the cells on
my um on my leg these aren't my germ
cells so these mutations even if the
cell survives will not be passed on to
my offspring that's an entirely
different discussion when we talk about
meiosis these are all my body cells and
they're replicating and we've gone over
this with with mitosis
mitosis so any mutations here they'll
either do nothing or the cells might
malfunction a little bit or the cells
might
hurt themselves or hurt me but they're
not going to affect my offspring i want
to make that point very clear now you're
saying hey sal 100 billion new cells a
day
i must you know that must mean like
every cell in my body is recreated well
and that just gives you an idea of how
many cells we have we actually have on
the order of
and you know it's obviously not an exact
number but there's actually in the human
body there's on the order of 100
trillion cells
100 trillion cells and if you look at it
that way you say on average 1 000
of your cells replicate each day but the
reality is some cells don't replicate
that frequently at all and some cells
replicate much more frequently but this
just gives you i mean you know just to
take a little side note here this gives
you an appreciation i think for the
complexity of the human body and we
think of our own
uh
world economy and and world society is
so complex it's made up of six billion
humans we're made up of a hundred
trillion cells a hundred trillion let me
rewrite 100 trillion in billions a
hundred trillion can be rewritten as one
hundred
billion
cells and each one of those hundred
thousand billion billion cells are these
uh huge i i don't i didn't use the word
hues but they're these complex
they're these complex ecosystems in and
of themselves with their nucleus is and
we'll talk about all the different
organelles they have and we talked about
cellular replication dna replication and
how the cell replicates so these things
aren't jokes and they have all of these
you know these complex membranes that
take things into them and you know they
are creatures to themselves but they
live in this complex uh you can almost
view an environment or society that is
that is each of us so that's just a side
note just to appreciate how large and
how complex we are
but you can imagine
as and this is how i got off on this
tangent if we're making on the if we're
making on the order 100 billion new
cells every day you're going to have a
lot of mutations and maybe some of the
mutations uh you know i said some of
them don't do anything some of them the
cell recognizes that the cell is just
going to be kind of uh
you know dead weight so the st the cell
kind of eliminates itself but every now
and then you have mutations where the
cell doesn't eliminate itself and it
also deforms the cell
so when you have that let's say i have
some cell here
i have some cell
and it's got some mutation i'll do that
mutation with a little with a little x
right here
with a little x that's it's in a dna
maybe it's got a couple of mutations so
one of the mutation keeps it from
experiencing apoptosis or destroying
itself and maybe one of the mutations
makes it replicate a little bit faster
than its neighbors so this cell through
mitosis
and makes a bunch of copies of itself
a ton of copies of itself
and this kind of body of cells
this body of cells that essentially has
a defect they're all from one
original cell that kept duplicating and
then those duplicating but all of these
are defective cells if you were to look
at them in in kind of a you know on
compared to the tissue around it it
would look abnormal in some way maybe it
wouldn't function properly this is
called a neoplasm
neoplasm
now a lot of neoplasms well they don't
have to form a body like this sometimes
they might somehow circulate in the body
but most of the times they form this
kind of this big lump and if they get
large enough they're noticeable and
that's when we call it a tumor
so if this is if this is actually a lump
a lump of kind of differentiate of
tissue that's definitely abnormal that's
what you call a tumor so the term
neoplasm and tumor are often used
interchangeably tumor is the word we use
more in our everyday
vocabulary now if these kind of if this
lump just kind of grows to a certain
size but it doesn't you know it's just
there doesn't really do anything
dangerous it's not it's not it's not
replicating out of control i guess it's
not replicating a lot faster than its
neighboring cells and it's just hanging
out maybe growing a little bit but and
not in any significant way harming our
environment
we call that a benign tumor or benign
neoplasm
benign and benign essentially means
harmless benign tumor
that means if it's you know that's
that's good you want to hear that if you
got a lump uh god forbid you you have a
lump either way but if you do it's a
benign tumor that means you know that
lump it can kind of stick around no
damage done but if these if these if
these dna mutations maybe some of these
are it is benign but maybe one of the
benign ones has another mutation
in it that starts making it grow like
crazy
grow like
crazy and not only does it grow like
crazy but it becomes invasive and
invasive means that it starts it doesn't
care what's going on around it it just
wants to infiltrate everything so let's
say that guy grows like crazy
and he starts let me do a different
color and he starts infiltrating other
tissue
so he's invasive
invasive so super growth
super growth
he's invasive so he starts he doesn't
care what's going on he's not all of a
sudden turned into some type of cellular
psychopath and even worse his
descendants it's not just one cell
anymore he just keeps duplicating and
passing on this kind of
a broken genetic information that makes
it want to replicate and then maybe more
even more
you know there could be more and more
uh
things that break down in its uh i guess
offspring or or the the dna that comes
from its replications and actually
that's that's a good likelihood because
the same parts of its dna that broke
down some of the some of the dna that
that broke down in this guy some of the
mutations might have actually hurt the
dna replication scheme so that mutations
become more frequent
so more frequent mutations
more frequent so as they as these
replicate more and more mutations appear
and then maybe eventually one of the
mutations appears it allows these cells
to break off
break off and then travel to other parts
of the body
to travel to other parts of the body and
then in those parts of the body start to
take over and start taking over all of
the cells and this process is called
the the cell has meta this is one of the
hardest words for me to say something
wrong with my brain but the cell has
metastasized
metastasized you might have heard the
word metastasis and that's just the
notion of these these run amok cells all
of a sudden all of a sudden being able
to travel to different parts of the body
and i think you guys know what we call
these cells these cells that aren't
respecting their cellular neighborhood
they're growing
like crazy they don't experience that
contact inhibition they're invasive they
they start they start crowding out other
cells and hogging up the resources and
they keep mutating really fast because
they have all these genetic
abnormalities and eventually they might
even break away and start infiltrating
other parts of the body these are
cancers or cancer cells
cancer cells and so you might have an
appreciation for why this is so hard
cancer is such a a hard disease to to
quote unquote cure because it really
isn't just one disease it's not like one
type of bacteria or one type of virus
that you can pinpoint and say let's
attack this
cancer is a whole class of mutations
where the cells start exhibiting this
fast invasive growth and this metastasis
so you know you might look at one type
of cancer and be able to say hey let's
target you know the mutation that where
the cell where the cells look like this
and you're able to knock out you're able
to knock out some of them let me do a
this in this color so maybe you're able
to knock out that guy that guy that guy
but they're the because their dna
replication system might be broken in
some way they continue to mutate so
eventually you have one version that's
able to not be knocked out by whatever
method you get and so you have this kind
of new form of cancer and then that new
form of cancer is even harder to kill so
you can imagine that cancer is a it's
kind of a never-ending fight and you
kind of have to attack the general idea
behind it when you when you uh
chemotherapy and radiation all of these
type of things they try to attack things
that are fast-growing because that's the
kind of one common theme behind all the
cancers and we could do a whole playlist
on on you know what cancer is and how
people are attacking it but i wanted to
at least show you in this video that
cancer really is just a byproduct of
broken mitosis or bro or any even more
specifically broken dna replication
that we have all of these
all of the all of these cells
replicating themselves every day you
know on the order of hundred billion and
every now and then something breaks
usually when they break the cell either
nothing happens or the cell kills itself
but every now and then the cells start
replicating you know even though they're
broken and sometimes they start
replicating like crazy if they just
replicate but they're really not doing
any harm it's a benign but if they start
replicating like crazy taking over
resources and spreading through the body
you're dealing with a cancer so
hopefully you found that interesting we
already already know a good bit of the
science that kind of
deals with uh what is probably you know
one of the one of the worst uh ailments
that that we deal with as as as as
creatures and obviously we're not the
only people who can experience cancers
even plants have cancers